the braves are going to try and get a
bounce back here as they'll send their
ace to the mound mike zaroka who did a
tremendous job in his opening day start
against the mets went six scoreless
against that lineup
so the reigns with first and second one
man out
and here's sutsugo 1-0 pitch
chopper out toward dansby fields steps
on the bag guns to first double play
and charlie morton is going to look to
bounce back the former brave the top
pick of the braves not too long ago
and that's the walk-up music of freddie
freeman
he struck out all four times in the game
last night this one he drives into
deep right field and that's going to be
out of the reach of renfro
acunu jr
headed to the plate and he's gonna be
out freeman at second but two down and
up steps marcelo zuna
tell you what we're learning the race
can run relays
going back to last october they can run
relays as well as anybody in this league
ozuna grounds one slowly back towards
the middle charging from shore to thomas
off balance throw from in front of the
bag
he got him in the side retired one out
and
nobody on here in the second kevin
kermeyer
digs in here ground ball to the right
side backhanded by freeman it's a foot
race
and it's won by freddie and adams one
for eight in the series the one was a
home run though
plating three runs swinging a pop-up on
the infield four infielders converging
third baseman wendell calls everybody
off and then it drops
and it's up to endurance here he comes
on the one-two another one swingled and
missed strike three a breaking ball that
dropped down
below the zone and morton strikes out
three in the inning
works around the error so one out the
base is empty and here's mike cenino
ground ball hit to third a second bounce
is backhanded by austin reilly and his
throw to first is accurate
boy was that a good play they get a man
to scoring position for freddie freeman
swing and a high fly ball to right
renfro going back
he's at the wall it's gone a home run
for freddie freeman
a two-run home run his first of the year
and the braves have the lead two-nothing
here's matt adams
matt adams reached on an error by joey
wendell this first time one on one out
two in for atlanta they're up two
nothing here in the bottom of the third
infield playing in the pool here's a
swing and a live drive and this is going
to be
caught up on a slide by caremeyer nice
play stumbles as he gets up
he was going to try and make it throw to
first base but holds on to the baseball
as that ball was hit rather sharply but
caremeyer got a great break
and was able to run it down before it
hit the ground and there's two outs
and it's first and second with two out
brandon lau
oh for two coming up as the possible
go-ahead run abdominus from seconds and
nino at first
the end of the dirt pops up runner tried
to advance and the throw
goes into left raves are going to get a
run adamus will cross the plate
with cenino moving up to second and the
raids are on the board making it a 2-1
game
and two and two to allow and the pitch
swing and a miss struck him out on a
change up loud
fires his bat away and that'll end the
inning
two out and bases empty here comes the
home run bat of freddie freeman a two
run homer and a double in this game
first pitch to freddie grounded to the
left side where nobody's positioned
and he's going to have a base hit right
off his thumbs
that rolled out towards short and he's
got a huge smile on his face
first and second two out for adams who
has reached on an error and lined out
owen to the count and the curveball
lifted in the air towards left
pushing margot back to the warning track
at the wall jumps up makes the catch
side retired matt adams just missed
blowing the game open but
instead manny margot went up against the
wall and pulled it down
and morton escaped the fifth inning with
no more damage
and now it will take something from the
left-hand band and kevin kiermeier
and the pitch soft liner left center
that gets in for a base hit
on owen two wendell around third he will
score
trying for third diaz head first dive he
is safe at third base
on oh and two kevin kiermeier delivers
and the rays have tied it at two
the rays have tied it and have diaz the
third is the go ahead run for hunter
renfro
now the two one pitch swinging a line
drive to the left for a base head
here is diaz to score kirmar heads for
home and the throw is cut off
another pair of two out runs hunter
renfro delivers
and the reys have a 4-2 lead in atlanta
and it'll be zanino and o'day
with renfrow at second adamus at first
4-2 to
raise lead over the braves were in the
sixth inning
chaos pitch runners going swinging a
miss struck him out and the inning is
over
swanson tonight one for two single to
ride his first time up and he also
struck out
another one-two offering to swanson
and a fly ball well hit to left marco
going back not gonna get it that's gonna
bounce into the bullpen
that's a ground rule double dansby
swanson continues his
torrid start and the braves get their
third run it's four to three on
back to back doubles so it's left to
ozzy albies
ozzy with that open stance a little
chopper they're in the shift might be a
tough play
ozzy beats the wrap
game tied on an infield head and freddy
freeman the batter
be a good spot for that triple it sure
would
freddy's got the single double and homer
the pitch
line driving to center field a base head
here comes ender around third he's gonna
score
ozzy headed for third and he is out
the run scores before the out and the
braves take the lead it's five to four
on the rbi hit
by freeman and now here's travis darnow
and he could really
give the braves some breathing room here
another payoff pitch to darneau
he's hit in the air to right field
slicing toward renfro
gets behind it catch is made ozuna tags
the third heads to the plate the throw
is offline and he scores standing
it's 6-4 atlanta on the sac fly to right
by travis darno excellent a-b
what a great at-bat one out now for
dansby swanson and it's a 6-4
atlanta lead two balls and a strike
pitch on the
way sharply hit oh what a stop by adamus
to rob him of a hit but he threw it away
and camargo's going to come home and
score
what an unbelievable stop by adamus he
would have cut off the run but he rushed
his throw and the braves cash it in
the sacks are full for ozzy aldi's now
the one-two pitch on its way
swing and a miss he struck him
here's brandon lau braves have held him
down in this game he's over four with
three strikeouts
on one pitch sharply hit
riley long throw and what a way to end
it